you made it you made it you made it oh
yeah you made it
it you made it weird with Pete
hes what's happening weirdos this is uh
this is exciting this is Mike biglia we
um we recorded this when I was in New
York just a week ago and we shot it in
his Studio so if you're watching this on
the video it's going to be a little bit
different uh it's going to look like
Mike studio and also the first I think
it's like 10 or 15 minutes are there's
no video so on Youtube it'll be whatever
whatever Joe throws up there but the
video will kick in uh about 10 or 15
minutes into the conversation so if you
only want to see it you can skip ahead
to that but uh you can listen to it the
whole way through um so happy you guys
are here not much to say up top uh my
Netflix special I am not for everyone is
available now we have new Batman videos
on my YouTube channel which is at Pete
Holmes hope you guys like those and uh
tour tickets R PE homes.com all that
stuff pretty easy stuff pretty easy this
episode is brought To Us by one of my
absolute favorite pizza pcks in the
world which is modern mammals which is
what is it I could I can basically say
this in 5 seconds modern mammals is a
shampoo that's like not a shampoo
because when you wash your hair with
shampoo your hair looks like [__] it
looks like absolute [__] it looks like a
bail of hay that you put in the dryer
and then you stapled to your head looks
terrible my whole life I didn't wash my
hair when I wanted my hair to look good
modern mammals comes in I don't know how
they did it they develop this new
formula it's kind of like mud you rub
rub it in your hands smells great rub it
through your uh hair and you rinse it
out it cleans it so we're talking comb
brush goes right through feels great
looks great but it looks great that's
the key is it looks like I wash my hair
hair yesterday it's [__] nuts I wash
my hair now before I go on TV that's in
like I did the talk this week wash my
hair before I go on the talk what is
going on they figured it out it's
shampoo that cleans your hair but makes
it look like you didn't wash your hair
with shampoo it's a total total Game
Changer they have bars which are ph
balanced fragrance-free minimalist
packaging no plastic so if you want like
an Earth friendly great way to easily
rub it in your hand get in here clean
your hair without ruining your hair or
they have it in the more traditional
kind of shampoo style goo that you know
goo shampoo is goo I like that one too
it is incredible if you want the wave it
gives your hair that this swoosh this
swoosh I don't put any product in it I
just wash it with modern mammals 30
seconds to perfect hair I [__] love
it it's a
GameChanger over 40,000 guys have
switched to this instead of traditional
shampoo you got to see the reviews guys
are losing their mind it blows their
mind once you use it I swear you're
hooked for life I am hooked for life you
can't go back to regular shampoo after
this and it's a small Grassroots punk
rock company these guys were just fed up
with shampoo frying their hair and they
set out to create something new for guys
to have perfect hair a shampoo
alternative it's 6 seconds to have a
perfect hair day on demand modern
mammals couldn't can't say enough about
it go to Modern mammals. comom slwe
where people can get a combo deal and
try both the bar and the bottle for 44
bucks for both once you do it you're
never going back you're very very close
to perfect hair and never having that
tumble weed look for your big date or
your job interview or whatever you need
to look good for modern mammals. comom
SL weird also of course I'm wearing them
right now I only wear them the perfect
Jean I wore them from my Netflix special
the perfect Jean because they look
perfect but they also feel perfect I
like stretchy pants but these are
stretchy pants that don't look like
stretchy pants in fact they don't even
really they do feel like stretchy pants
but you don't feel like you're wearing
yoga pants or PJ pants but they're kind
of somewhere in the middle there meaning
it's 2% spandex 2.5% rayon although they
have a new 99% cotton version which are
dope they also make khaki jeans like c k
jeans khaki jeans they have it they have
you covered they have your lower half
covered and they stretch I don't know
why we're not wearing these pants these
pants are total game changers they give
you extra room so you're nuts aren't
crushed your nuts ain't crushed and they
provide the only true home for your bone
they're also incredibly incredibly
well-crafted the colors are awesome
they're basically high-end designer
jeans that feel as comfortable as a
baby's butt you might even forget you're
wearing pants I love them I did a
complete overhaul the perfect Jean has
changed my Jean game they look
incredible and they're comfortable
enough to sleep in I have I have slept
in them and they're not they're not just
[__] cotton khakis if you want khakis
you get the Khaki colored ones look
dressy [__] great and spare your nuts
everybody spare your nuts the perfect
Jean for the Perfectly Imperfect men 20
% off when you use code weirdo at
checkout liberate your lower limbs with
the one and only perfect Gene whether
you're working with lemons or lentils a
three leaf clover or a big old honken
eggplant the perfect Gene has got you
covered take a peek at the perfect gene.
NC that's the perfect
jan. NC use code weirdo for 20% off at
checkout and thank me later modern
mammals perfect Jean two standards get
them both get them for someone you love
this holiday season pretty much any man
that washes his hair and wants to look
good or wears jeans and wants to look
and feel good modern mammals per jeene
boom thank me later all right enjoy my
chat with the wonderful Mike biglia
whose uh new special uh the old man in
the pool will be or is available I
should have looked that
up it either will be or is available I'm
pretty sure it is available on
netflix.com the website it's incredible
I've seen it several times check it out
check out everything Mike does check out
his podcast uh working it out he's so
good and one of my dearest friends we
make fun of each other a lot in this
podcast but know that that's out of love
and don't forget to get into it let me
start by
saying we've
seen we had a sleepover last night I
think we should talk about that we did
have a sleep I know it's your podcast
but we should I don't mind
buddy I could use a day off
you know what I mean oh I know I know
you know well sometimes I go on podcasts
and either they take over or I take over
and I'm kind of good with either either
way yeah yeah if someone takes over yes
well I'm stealing that phrase from Conan
who we were just talking about this guy
he said uh Marty Short Martin Short is a
day off I've said that many times I love
that because that's always been my goal
when I do late night is I want the host
to say you're a day off I'm always
unabashedly going for thank you for
making it so I could just not just sit
there yeah but they don't have to steer
they can laugh they can interject but
they don't have to pull it out of you
everything's like that like I think
marriage is like that to an extent right
Mark marriage Mark marriage yeah like I
think I think that um I think that
marriage is like that in the sense that
it's like sometimes it's not that doing
the dishes is hard we all know how to do
the dishes it's the act of like you show
up and they're done yeah that's right
there's something about day off yeah
you're a day off no that's one of the
biggest cliches that is true is that
like and not even sex it sounds when I
say like doing the dishes is foreplay it
means like V's going to give me what I
want yes which is a right [__] it's
not that wow you be you can become that
guy I'm not no that's you that's a part
of you like a more popular comedian like
if I was saying things like that people
would be like thank
you yes yeah uh right you do look much
better today speaking and making fun of
each other and more and more well rested
I'm glad I was worried about you we so
we did your podcast in for 20 minutes I
was like are you on your way out like
you look like you looked like a medium I
wanted to ask you to ask questions to
dead people I know cuz you looked like
you had one foot in the river sticks I
get it I get it so to give context PD
and I have been friends for a long long
time and uh long time borderline maybe
20 years or something borderline
personality disorder borderline
borderline personality 20 years and uh
and and then we've been on each other's
podcasts a lot um and so he's
working it out might be my fifth time so
today I'm on you made it weird but
yesterday we recorded him on working it
out and there's great jokes on there
that are new jokes working out L um but
you came but we met on a Sunday cuz
you're on
tour yeah I just done DC and I came in
on Sunday and you're not used to
recording on Sunday so you came in
looking
like I mean you look squashed yeah yeah
I looked like something was wrong and I
looked all I mean I felt Juiced like I
had been
working like you know I had done shows
the night prior so when we were
recording I had been on stage like 12
hours earlier yes or maybe less so I
felt like viral and ready to go and you
looked like I was interrupting a family
man Sunday yes so you saw family you saw
family mic and then this morning you
slept over our house and I morning I'm
morning M and I said this is key I'm
glad you're good this is good this is
worth mentioning I saw you I was on your
little outdoor area yeah and I saw you
through the glass getting coffee or you
know shuffling around yeah in basically
you know those slippers that are bare
feet you didn't have those on but that
was the vibe yeah yep and I was like oh
my God Mike is uh you know me in the
morning comedian yeah and we do yes like
what element does a does a comic let you
into their life Seinfeld he had you over
for dinner maybe or lunch no I never had
no no no I don't mean literally I mean
like his audience knows him in a suit oh
okay I follow we know you getting an AO
out of the
toaster oh that's what you're saying
that's what I'm saying oh I didn't even
follow that
it it's it's kind of an indication of
the intimacy level you go like I'm a
little tired I'm a little raw right like
and I just need to kind of tell somebody
I'm enjoying this this story enjoying
this impression what's funny is you talk
that way offstage too we had dinner last
night and every once in a while we're
all kind of Performing cuz it was a
bunch of performers I don't mean it as a
bad thing yeah but it' come back to you
and you'd be like no I know and I'm like
wow and then you'd tell this great you
had dinner with Marty schw we're back
yeah yeah yeah what happened tell me
about a dinner with Marty schw I will'll
ask you about old man in the pool which
premieres on Netflix yeah the and thank
you and thanks for you probably saw old
man in the pool three of course I did
two or three times probably of course I
did I and I loved it and it was
fantastic and there's a drawing of the
of the set design which I really
appreciated W you're so deliberate like
I feel like I'm out there I'm a patch of
wild growing Irish moss that every once
in a while I'm like look at that it
really looks beautiful and you're out
there making us all look dumb cuz you're
you got like a bonsai tree and you're
trimming it and you're putting clean
white stones at the base that's what I
mean by the set design and the light
design the lights shift and I'm sitting
in the crowd going like what the [__]
and you know what can I also give you
another compliment oh please when we
were I want I was I was about to
discredit myself and just be like that
was Seth beish and beay wolf barit and
Hana and Aaron and all these design all
the curators do they go but I ask
someone to do it shut up you still ask
someone to do it right right doesn't oh
you got help right I'm not asking for
help and that was the other thing when
we were doing bits and I'm just so
privileged to be your friend friend is
that I would tell you like I'm working
on a joke about thinking about getting a
vasectomy this is not a spoiler you
should still listen to working it out
it's great but like you always and in
your own work go towards the real thing
and I'm saying like oh having a child is
so much harder than I thought and then I
had some funny vasectomy jokes and
you're like no talk about that you know
like how it's so hard yeah that's the
secret and I know we've said this every
time we talk but like what is the secret
we both of us tear up by the way you
were like oh our episode was a
two-parter and then you're like no it's
a one parter last night which which you
said as a burn kind of and you told that
to Jud you were like hey we did this
2hour episode cuz I was like maybe it'll
be a two-parter and then I'm like this
isn't as good it's a onep parter and I'm
sitting there like a schmuck no as I go
to bed last night just a little bit as I
go to bed last night I'm like the part
where I told you the secrets I tell
about my parents part two wacko Jacko
where you died laughing wacko Jack is
amazing yeah it's all in part two it's
in the second half no you're right what
do you want to happen I said you got
tired after not during so after you're
tired and you're like what am I crazy
that's nothing yeah no you're right
you're right I got defensive let's see
if it I think it still will be a onear
that's the Pete Holmes I think that's
the Pete Holmes Achilles heel defensive
because as you know I love you I love
you I love you love your comedy love
your new special love your tour love
your new jokes what's the heel that I
get I think you get defensive I think I
do too I think you have something that
is kind of like Corner dog when you're
not Corner dog you're I feel so seen and
loved right now because I told you so
last night
Jud oo's husband Ryan yeah and Jenny and
and Jenny your wife and me and my
daughter
yeah we're all here at the apartment I
hate when people go like and she was my
date but I did feel a bond with una oh
God and she was my date I hate Universe
me too my dad goes how's my little
girlfriend I'm like God stop it stop
stop please stop stop let me stop let me
cut you off right there but we're not I
we're that's a level of closeness we
don't have I can't be like will you
[__] stop that's gross I can't I just
have to be like well she's doing very
well
sir what I meant was I en I was enjoying
Uno we were writing poems together we
were having laughs together uh so I felt
accompanied like a friend she's pure joy
she's pure joy that's all I mean so
anyhoo uh what was I saying oh so the
cornered
thing we're going to bring it right back
to you but that no I know but this is
your episode but as this is good audio
of a friend lovingly saying like hey I
said hey I noticed you look like you're
going to die
you you said it to my wife and
fortunately my daughter my is Mike okay
like but you look great right now that's
really funny I needed some time to just
get accustomed to how translucent you
are oh god well you and I and hopefully
we won't do it again today on my episode
of working it out we just burn each
other for like 10 minutes straight a lot
of burning we come at each other so hard
lot of Bill Bur Impressions too a lot of
Bill bur Impressions you I mean you do
it on your podcast but on mine you did a
lot you went into every impression every
person that came up Swiss Army
impression man it was Swiss Army and
just like a Swiss Army you know I
wouldn't cut a piece of paper with those
scissors but you know they they are
scissors technically they're scissors so
anyway my wound and Val knows this is if
I start to feel like I'm Vanishing which
is so weird because all of my
metaphysical and spiritual Pursuits is
to come to peace with the idea that
we're not special and then it's all just
kind of like this one magnificent thing
it's not about an individual identity
but if you start taking away my
individual identity against my will so
this will happen sometimes with dinner
parties with Val and it was happening a
little bit last night where it was me
you and Jed and Jenny and I know my
place in that and then two new people
come who are wonderful and I actually
really want them to like me yeah and so
it's just different it brings me back to
to Junior High and that
defensiveness that you hear when I say
that's in the second part that you're
saying needs to be cut that's in the
second part I'm grateful for it I'm
going to put this to you too my wound is
also my strength yeah the thing that is
our downfall is all the other side of it
is the pointy spear that we use to like
get through the cobwebs so two things to
unpack from this one is I'm sorry I'm
not done talking okay I'm just kidding I
was talking so she was too much please
so a couple things to unpack one is I
had you
over and you really to your credit you
went out of your way to come from DC up
to New York I was like I saw your tour
schedule you're one of the favorite
alltime working out guests of all time
people people email me about it people
message in the comments on Instagram
they're all me
fake Phil
GMA speed homes wants you back I mean do
you know
him speed Homes at Hotmail um sne sne
pomes
gmail.com um sne
pes2 at
gmail um no so it was it's it's a
commonly and people will literally come
to my shows and say I love it when you
and Pete home Spar and so me we Spar
because we're not spars yeah people who
don't really spar with other the that
usually hold the bucket for the boxer to
spit in it's like what if they [__]
yes exactly what if they that's what it
is no that's great the but so so people
are like when's that again and I'm like
well we just live so far away from each
other that it never quite works and I
went to Los Angeles recently and Val
took you out on a little like getaway
thing and so you were like sorry I can't
do it oh yeah the surprise vacay right
where Val the joke there was Val just
saw I was in town but didn't see yes I
would say there a Valas here she laughed
too she was like I didn't see that every
day had lots of things planned but I'll
one for one you on the Val thing so so
I'm like will you come up and do the
podcast and it was we had never done a
Sunday we only do Monday through Friday
that's when everybody's in that's when
my staff's in and um I will do Sunday
and so you saw my Sunday self which is a
disaster it was and like a dad a dad the
dad from Parenthood basically the Steve
Martin from Parenthood kind of like
holding everything all at once and then
you saw morning mic this morning that
was the most natural mic I've ever seen
in my life I was like you've all you
should be by a coffee maker and it's
dripping in slowly and you're just
waiting for one cup to be in there so
you can let it Sizzle on the hot plate
and so so there's that and then oh this
is a kicker didn't tell you this last
night it would make you feel
self-conscious or I didn't want to let
on I let you I told you but I didn't
tell you too much
um I forgot I invited you to stay
overnight so we finish our podcast
recording and he you and I had had text
messages that were very loose and so I'm
going to contend that but
like I could pull it up right now but I
don't have to you can trust me when you
said you can stay here and I'd say that
sounds great yes so that happened cuz
it's 800 bucks no no I mean New York
hotels are
holid in 800 bucks it's every city right
now by the way it's it's Chicago's like
that and there's no non 800 option maybe
I DC is like that right now but New York
is particularly egregious hey hey Gary
oh man you rushed you're okay you're
okay sorry to rush everybody it's my
vuck up he's he has to catch a train at
noon okay hi we've been recording for
this we've been recording for this long
guys are okay it's all good yeah yeah
yeah it's all meow it's all mow this
will just be for a clip or something
it's it's so nice thank you for being
here yeah so we've been recording for 15
um for for Pete's show and then and then
the Whatever video we get we'll get and
we can also um those lights I know it's
nice right see everything you're doing
and see unlike your show we're not going
to edit this out I like this I like them
to hear we're going to cut it out and
send it to you
cut we're going to send it to you cut is
such a
funny you said it sort of mean like I'm
not kidding you will not get this no we
will no no you won't this is this is my
this is the show my show is soda can
opening no no staff discussing I can't
allow it you laughing I can't allow it
because Mike we got to hear like people
need to know that there are comedians
like you that employ other comedians
first of all and that speak to them uh
compassionately kindly and uh let them
behind the curtain a little bit Gary get
the [__] out of here turn the [__]
camera G and get out of here Gary's
sweaty he went up the stairs too fast M
close that closet Mabel's Mabel's sorry
to be check it feels too personal be
checking your sweat levels but Mabel's
cool as a Cuke no I know Mabel's fine
yeah yeah that Mabel I I pointed out
before Mabel for bble
is 22 it was 22 never afraid I'm like I
was more afraid when I was 22 I was
afraid of everything I got married when
I was 22 oh my God can you I can't
believe that you got married when you're
22 this is not how I really feel but I
remember after I got divorced I was like
why didn't anyone stop me somebody sto
me yeah but you didn't you didn't have
anyone in your life who who would have
stopped you that's true cuz I'm know I'm
thinking about who was in your life at
that time and it was a lot of people who
were like raah Rah raah Christianity for
sure if I well that's why you need a
Mike biglia oh yeah you well that's why
you need a friend that goes you are in
fact the consumate friend that goes what
are you doing that's why even roasting
you that you looked
unwell oh yeah that's me so Gary and
mael you guys missed yesterday on the
podcast or Gary didn't that um I was
concerned for Mike but what literally
was like are you okay what service am I
to I know Mabel's like thank you someone
said it see you guys are all like the
Frog getting slowly boiled I walk in and
I jump out of the hot water and I go
Mike's Mike's not
good I'm going to speak to the camera
and say we're on Pete homes you made it
weird I'm Mike biglia we you look like
you only eat honeycomb cereal okay this
will make no sense in this context I'm
trying to set up your video for your
YouTube channel brought To Us by
honeycomb cereal based on your
complexion this is you made it weird um
I Mike bigley I'm the guest the video
today is only uh from now until the end
the the audio you can listen to the
first 15 minutes on any Apple podcast
anywhere you listen to you made it weird
I like when people say wherever you find
podcast podcast I don't know sometimes I
say whomever you find your podcast but
here on uh
youtube.com you can watch the last 40
minutes mhm mhm which is not
bad the first 20 wasn't that great I'm
just kidding I liked it see that's
something I feel like you would say the
last 50 50 I think so it's it's only 101
only 101 great great 101 10 10
10 I can't do burr anymore I did it too
much
yesterday we went we went so hard on
Bill bur impressions in the episode
yesterday I wish you could tell
I thought it was very interesting that
you said like Bill loves comedy but he's
he doesn't he's not super aware of you
or or me like he's focused on his thing
and then he has other
interests fair to what I've heard is I'm
not close to them it's like what I've
heard is he's really into like drumming
right and like sports I think that's
completely I think that's true based on
my experience but that means he's like a
kind of like more like a real like a
real person I back it yeah well you and
I get together and we're not talking
about anything except comedy we talk
about Bill Burr we we talk about Bill
Burr B out there talk J exactly yeah
should we go back to that yeah so okay
so the two things I want to point out
about last night yeah and I'll bring
Gary and Mabel up to speed on this
because they didn't know so but they
know my habits they know that this kind
of thing would be true yeah so we record
working it out with Pete and at the end
of it he goes so I'm staying
overnight yeah I'm like where should I
my bag where should I yeah we talked
about it I'm staying overnight you
invited me to stay overnight yes yes you
are yes you are you're flattering
yourself you weren't that good at it you
were like oh what I should have said was
Marriott yeah I I spoke in my own joke
structure from
2007 for some reason still on the
wall you want to distance yourself from
it maybe don't frame it and hang it
out we're we're by the way in the
working it out studio and we are
surrounded by by tour posters and
special posters which is what pet is R I
should have said was nothing is framed
to my right so you didn't know I was I
didn't know and then I went and then I
weirdly I went down to Jen and I go okay
so Pete is I I offered to have him stay
overnight so he's staying overnight and
she goes where and I go
I don't know yet um he could St you have
a couch yeah I go we he could stay in
the office but also I go we could have
una sleep in our bedroom in the bonus
bed on on the floor and then he could
sleep in una's bed and Bon and then we
had to measure Pete and see if he would
fit in una's bed yeah I'm he and he
doesn't spoiler alert he doesn't but he
slept there anyway I don't fit in most
beds me and Gman me and Gman aren't
fitting in any beds that's a wild thing
so travels I wake up and I'm pinned down
by a a tiny
civilization most
days so part two of this is you said to
me we're walking down these steps you go
I'm staying overnight I'm thinking
myself okay all right so that's
happening and then and then you go and I
invited J appau over uh to have D okay
and I love Jud he had he come over the
other night for dinner too invited Jud
to have dinner and we would meet here
and you were welcome to join if you
wanted okay it turned into a family
style and then I had invited oo akaza
who's a comedian friend who's been on
working out a lot and and has been on
you made it weird right
yeah and and her husband Ryan so then it
all of a sudden it became like seven
people uh at a dinner party and it was
and a sleepover and a sleepover so it
was dinner dinner party sleepover and it
was I think Gary and Mabel will relate
to this and and
uh the difference between and I think
this could be a bit a five person dinner
party and a seven person dinner party
all of a sudden totally different that's
exactly what I'm saying and this is a
bit by the way I don't even know what
the jokes are but mark my words it's
like you steal that bit or I steal that
bit and put it on stage and that thing
will work people know people know you
got five people it's civil seven seven
people somehow taking shifts well
somehow you're at the WWE you're at like
a you're like a monster truck you're
watching different constellations of
three momentarily take the focus and you
know what else happens with seven that
wasn't happening with five
lulls yeah every and they they've timed
it psychologists have done studies every
seven minutes we would just be
like yeah yeah here's the other one and
Ryan will be comfortable me saying this
because we're we're close friends so I
say to oo I go so oo I want to talk you
to talk to una because some of the boys
at school they just they chase her
around like did you have that as a kid
she starts answering as she's answering
Ryan starts talking to me on my right
yeah so o goes on my left he's I go no
did you just what what are you doing I
just asked about something else she's
yeah about something else totally
different thing yeah they like we got to
keep these conversations under control
there's only seven of us here come on
but it is over the limit it's over the
limit see I'll start to vanish what is
the limit let's establish a
limit Gary Mabel what do you think
what's the what's the right amount of
people
Gary I like four to five G says four to
five mael says four to five I think you
know why because in seven this happened
when you said that the girl the boys
won't stop cha chasing una I had a
response I'm sure Jen had a response I'm
sure oo had a response Ryan had a
response so you hold it yeah and now you
have conversation kind of you know
you're backed up but you're waiting and
by the time the window opens it's too
late and that's what a lull
is that's what a lull is that's a good B
bring it on working out Bring It On
working out we're on working out baby I
know I know this is a crossover episode
this is like like when Al walks into
cheers hey hey Sam Malone kill
me you're right this is a crossover this
is when the critic was on The Simpsons
yep it
stinks I never saw that but the critic I
believe you critic was great anyway
we're two comics and you guys are Comics
as well right you got into this because
you were like let's let's clean up the
Hedge maze okay of conversation of
parties right all people think it's
narcissism it's not it's a relief for
everybody yes I'll talk
I know I'll talk I know that you feel
that way you do too we all know that you
feel you it's compassionate dare think
of an how dare you do you do too as an
insult you do too you just got you
doed you just got
you because you do to it's nice you look
when you when I started there was a lot
more ego in it it was like finally I'm
going to get my the attention that I
deserve I swear I feel more in touch
with the like this was nice of me to
think of something we could all enjoy
just like a song you know what I mean
you like I work with Glenn hanser that
man just wants everyone to have a good
sing
song he wants to have a good sing song
and he wants you to forget your troubles
as I get older the more I'm more
answered than I am 22-year-old Pete who
was getting married and doing Sant
comedy good combo that's a good combo
you want to pursue the most difficult
career path and also get Christian
mingled but let's all right let's bring
the dinner party into the universe of
standup comedy really
similar it's it's arguably a or you know
what it's more like it's more like an
improv
scene well that's why five people or
seven people at a dinner party it's an
improv scene you know what old homes
used to do Twan improv you know why what
am I going to two improv we talk about
it here all the time Chris G and Tammy
Seer are doing it right now I'm going to
stand on the back wall and watch you
guys do a
show [__] beat it you know you know
what the problem with the Don't Think
Twice guys are too many of them [__]
beat they can't all shine so geth's all
should I put drawings in my submission
beat it you should have been in every
scene no breaks then you become
Keegan you want to be
Keegan do two
man or two person I should say
like human
man oh pety you're on fire this morning
all we needed Gary am my right about
Pete we just needed to get him some
sleep oh my God I did sleep about 12
hours last night it was [__] great w
you're a giant man you're you're so
you're so giant that animal control
might take you away by accident yeah
those tennis ball nets
yeah most days my day ends when the
tennis net F I saw you in an animal
control truck driving by I go good work
fellas yes I feel that I feel that yeah
you're big big guy let me I'll steer it
just because we don't have all the time
in the world to old men in the pool okay
and say that you it's about death that's
right do you think a lot about death cuz
yesterday it didn't look like you
do because I because I looked on the
verge of death like a man that was like
it'll be fine right I'll just eat white
bread and
mayonnaise
well that's literally Nick croll's
impression of me all the time he'll just
go does anyone have mayonnaise like
literally all right wow that's what
happens when you know someone since
College their impression of you dates
till like 1999 does anybody have some
mayonnaise oh God I want to go to Brun
just wait Gary and Mabel your friends
will mock you for things you did three
years ago does anybody have any manise
trying to do crawl that's good that's
okay you get you you you do a good job
getting your voice there yeah it's it's
singing It's pitch yeah that's what I've
noticed and that's why some days you
can't get it and it's cuz your throat is
off or whatever you know because you're
trying to
sing like when I did Morgan Freeman
yesterday you know what I mean because
my voice is warmed up and all that sort
stuff but some days you try it and it
comes out bad that's interesting yeah so
death so death yeah so am I thinking
about a lot um well what made you want
to do a show about it were you like this
is UN undiscovered like I'll I'll be the
first to kind no it's not that it's not
that it was uh it was just I think that
standup comedy is best when you're
discussing
Obsession and so by the
way that's all you get to
say on this show I had a feeling I
wouldn't get to say a lot well I felt
you I felt I felt you going into uh
press mode you were answering you were
answering a question so I'm going to
disrupt that [__] right here and say the
Latin word for passion passion was
Obsession and it was actually a bad
thing the passions yeah like it was
almost like look out for your passions
that's what that that's what the
biblical passions means is that talk the
passions of Christ no no no that just
means torture I don't know why they call
it passions yeah but I'm it was a king
some people
had
about Mur love I love this I wish we had
a crucifixion every day oh God but then
it wouldn't be special Mark oh God
exactly well Judi seems to want to do it
every day for what nine pieces of
silver uh okay so you're you're
passionate about
death no I'm obsessed oh obsessed I'm
Sor no it's it's
the it's the thing
of you and I'm not this isn't a press
talking Boy by the way this is like this
I just like keeping you on your toes I
get you
um I can
tell I can tell when Comics aren't
talking about the thing they're thinking
about I love what you just said what you
just said like when I induct you into
the comedy Hall of Fame and I'll get it
wrong I'll be like I'll never forget
I'll talk like my dad when Mike bigle
said I'm tired of comics not talking
about what I can tell they're thinking
about and we'll cut to John melany in a
glass jar he's floating in a blue liquid
wonderful why would we be he's miked why
would he be in the blue liquid he's
because he's something happened and he's
in a blue he's being suspended like Ted
Williams in a blue
liquid
stupendous
because it's the future I don't know why
he's in the blue liquid it's the future
I'm old you're old melan is the same age
in a blue liquid but he's just ahead is
it I've known Mike not yet John are
wealthier people in blue liquid yeah
yeah all the hot people are in blue
liquid okay the Kardashians blue liquid
Yep they're they're all floating in blue
liquid yep some people have the yellow
liquid yuck yeah yuck a good bit for its
time a very now people don't get it now
yeah this this coming from a yellow
liquid he hosts SEL 72 times in the
liquid so so so when you induct me into
the Hall of Fame and John mean's in blue
liquid and I look like jobba the Hut you
look like Paul Redd hasn't been outside
in 40 years yeah which I already look
like um the uh you would you would quote
the thing I just said basically like I
don't like watching Comics we went on a
rift henge but that is the one of the
most insightful things I've heard about
comedy ever and you've put uh words to a
feeling it's almost like you discovered
a flavor like we're eating chips for the
Fredo Corporation and you're like Umami
CU When I'm watching and I'm like that's
not how you feel that's not who you are
and frankly that's not even what you're
thinking about that's not what you're
thinking about and I know it and I know
isn't it weird how you know that that's
one of the things I've learned from
being a confessional comic people always
say I can't believe you tell people all
that stuff and I go like everybody knows
everybody's stuff that's so funny just
look it around you kind of know
everybody's stuff look around yeah
that's true you kind of know everybody's
stuff I I tried to do this for a while I
was like hey everybody out there that's
addicted to pornography we all
know that's funny we can see it in your
face yeah you can I I like that's not
entirely true cuz certainly there are
people that are getting away with it
yeah but you know there's a sunken eye
kind of there's a way that you scan
people's bodies you're just I know
you're thinking about dicks and puss
constantly everybody's just you're like
at a steakhouse and bodies are segmented
like filet yeah rump yeah because all
you do is look at two-dimensional images
of hardcore pornography yeah that
explains why this lunch is going so
[__] weird Beat It Elliot I just made
that up I don't know anyone named but
then you gave up pornography I try I I'm
light on myself if I if I have a little
I'm not rough I remember you did a while
back though I remember you talking to
you about it you were like I gave up
pornography I gave up this I gave up
this gave this what what I'm talking
about yeah I was always admiring of that
though that you had this kind of uh this
kind of self-improvement focus well I do
we talked about that this morning as I
was taking my element and drinking my
fiber and all this stuff I was like
there is a Christian a latent Christian
I'm impure so I need to like fix God yes
that's what you talking about yeah yeah
so that that's in there that's certainly
the self wait when I was pretending to
listen that's what you were talking
about yeah yeah yeah and by pretending
to listen you mean the synapses behind
your eyeballs hadn't yet and found like
the first 30 minutes of you to just like
yeah I just couldn't put words to it you
look like tapioca in the
microwave but then you finally came to
and we could barely tell to be honest
Gary mael are laughing in a way that I
don't like you it's you're really
nailing me and and these folks who work
on my podcast and and are my dear
friends uh are just like Peete is
nailing Mike in a way that that we maybe
couldn't without it being like over the
line this is what you do when I go and
do Conan's podcast you just make fun of
Conan because sta I did the same thing
with Conan they love it love it I think
he loves it too with Conan I'm a little
more a lot more gentle though keep in
mind this is your podcast yeah it
doesn't feel like it it doesn't feel
like because we did yours and you did
interview me and I'm allowing you to
interview me and I shouldn't okay but I
do I do forget what we're talking
about this show is sponsored by
betterhelp I love better help I love
therapy we talk about it a lot and how
it's changed my life and especially at
the end of the year the holidays can be
a really tricky time for me personally
and it's been super helpful to talk to a
professional in the past and still is
when I'm feeling those holiday Blues
it's kind of weird when everybody else
is so happy and you need to vent some
stuff but it's more than venting talking
to a professional is greater than the
sum of its parts it seems like you're
just talking to somebody but something
magical is happening that can be really
transformative and healing this time of
year can be a lot it's natural to feel
some sadness or anxiety about it but
feeling but adding something new and
positive to your life can counteract
some of those feelings and therapy can
be a bright spot amid all of the stress
and change something to look forward to
to make you feel grounded and to give
you the tools to manage everything going
on it helps with family stuff it helps
with boundaries work stuff obviously
relationships and all different types of
feelings talking about it helps it helps
so much so if you're thinking about
starting therapy give better help a try
it couldn't be easier it's entirely
online designed to be convenient
flexible and suited to your schedule you
just fill out a brief questionnaire to
get matched with a license therapist you
can even switch therapists at any time
for no additional charge so do something
new something positive feel grounded and
get to work on yourself trust me it
helps find your bright spot this season
with better help visit betterhelp.com
weirdo today to get 10% off your first
month that's betterhelp
hp.com weirdo for 10% off give yourself
a little extra boost this holiday season
also were're brought To Us by our
friends at ritual the best and only
multivitamin that I've ever taken that I
actually take and feel ready to start my
day I talk to so many people about
vitamins and they all kind of pooo it
like you just pee it out you know when
you take a multivitamin and your pee is
just green and you're like well that
that appears to be all of the vitamins I
just took ritual has figured it out not
only is it completely traceable it's
allergen-free it's got a minty taste
which I really enjoy and can fill the
gaps in a normal diet it can fill those
gaps I can speak to that from my own
visits to my doctor filling gaps really
helps you don't Peay it out cuz it's got
a delayed release it waits until it's in
your large intestine where they can
actually be absorbed and get into you so
the delayed release takes care of that
Predator blood situation plus I do a lot
of fasting if you've ever taken zinc on
an empty stomach you know it's it'll
make you barf it's your your stomach
does not want it the delayed release
takes care of that ritual is the perfect
multivitamin to take when you're fasting
first of all to get some of those
nutrients in you while you're not eating
but it also won't upset your stomach
it's specifically developed multivitamin
with key high quality nutrients in a
bioavailable form that are clean ritual
is a new type of 2 a day helping support
heart a healthy heart with omega-3 DHA
to normal muscle function to normal
immune function with vitamin D3 this
small step can have a Major Impact it's
traceable it's vegan friendly non- GMO
sugar-free gluten-free major allergen
free and as I said delayed release
designed to make it gentle on an empty
stomach and it even has a minty Essence
which makes it fun and a pleasure to
take essential for men is a quality
multivitamin from a company you can
actually trust trust and get this ritual
is offering weirdos 30% off your first
month during your first month visit
ritual.com weird that's ritual.com
weird do something to support the show
do something to support your body better
help ritual get into it all right let's
get back to Mike big
Leia I I'm one of those PE I have a
friend
who uh and this but also this hases into
death for sure go ahead tell me so in
other words like you were saying like
what you why do you talk about why you
why did you start talking about death I
started working on this special like
four years ago yeah and it was just an
obsession was what I was interested in
I'm sure you find this with
bits the fear I had I had one fear which
is oh this might be too close to home
for people who are uh dealing with death
right now yeah their parents just died
their friend just died whatever it is
and actually those are the people who
need it I was just going to say too
close to home you mean there's people in
the home yeah you'd like some people in
the home yeah the American strategy on
death is like go in that Shack that's on
that cliff and just be the there alone
there's no heat there's no furniture
just go sitting there for a while or
maybe stand it would be better if you
stand Blair Witch style that's our
strategy with death and if you're
talking I buddy you're talking to
somebody who's recently cut like 20
minutes of death stuff from my new hour
really yeah and a lot of it why no 20
stayed though it's just it was too much
okay it's all you were talking about but
like I wanted to talk about it I my a
guy a man who was like a second father
to me just just died and it's like let's
talk about let's get into it but I
know crowds don't want to they do though
they do I'm here to tell you I did an
hour and 20 on it my new special that's
the genius of going like come to a
Broadway show I you know what one of my
save lines used to be when I was
starting in comedy I was like I really
Envy theater yeah because if you do a
joke and it doesn't work the audience
goes maybe he's trying to be moving or
maybe it's like ironic you know what I
mean with me you know I'm failing
I don't I don't agree with that though I
I'm going to push back on you and I'm
going to say as your friend two things
one is I Workshop the old man in the
pool in comedy clubs and theaters so
it's like I don't think they need the
Broadway setup in the in the in the set
and all the stuff and especially your
shows you know I was talking to J dap
the other day about your audience your
audience is there for P that was very
good pizans is very special
what I was doing 40-Year-Old Virgin he
never talks about his movies he never
does okay so he was talking to me about
how he was at one of your shows and your
audiences are just like you know cuz you
wrote a book comedy sex god Etc like
they're interested in they're interested
in your relationship to religion they're
interested in your relationship to
existentialism and jokes Etc so like
this idea that you're saying you're
imposing on yourself yourself this
restriction on your act right now of
like oh I can't do that but I'm in I'm
in the middle which is actually a great
place to be let me tell you jud's
talking about my Largo show yeah when I
go and do DC every show there's at least
30% randos that are just like oh the E
Trade baby
whatever and then I start going that's a
hook sometimes the club uses it and I go
like I start talking about that I just
feel it and you know what Matt McCarthy
always says this too he goes maybe
you're uncomfortable you know like I
impose it on them what I'm saying yeah
yeah that's all I'm saying but you're a
good friend cuz when you and Jed said
that I was like oh no my new hour I
don't have I'm not trying to be
formulaic but I'm like I don't have a
new God joke do you want to hear my
premise kind of working it out please
yeah I go my God is love and I I really
miss the old one my God is so loving the
God that I believe in now yeah so the
ground of being accepting yeah accepting
neutral actually yeah just made of love
in the way that water is made of wet
yeah my God won't talk [__] he's not mad
at me it's [__] it's a snooze yeah
like I missed the God that was Old
Testament God that was like he jerked
off again and they send the the Angels
yeah to [__] get me it was like Jason
Bourne movie yes and now my God you sit
in a bar with him and you're like
[__] Mike bigan right he's always
giving me [__] and he's like Mike's
doing his
best I love that God Mike's doing his
best I love Mike and when I'm in my
heart that's how I feel about everybody
right you know what I'm saying like I go
like I don't want Bill Mah to believe in
God I'm like look at that perfect peace
perfect peace he defines the others you
know we all Define one another bill
marah's atheism defines my theism you
know what I mean but we only want one
side of the coin [__] off that was the
faith I grew up in it's like what if the
whole field was daisies right and I'm
like no it's Thorns it's weeds it's well
it's funny it's everything you and I
were talking about this this morning
someone asked me do I believe in ghosts
do I believe in uh Loch nness Monster
this and that like sure I don't know
yeah like that's my answer to like
anything that is outside of the
parameters of the thing that culture
believes in as an accept it I just go
like if someone if if five people came
up to me and they say I just saw a
monster it's 100 feet tall i' I wouldn't
go no you didn't I go like tell me more
about that I I didn't see that but I
don't think that you have a motivation
to come over to me and tell me there's a
100 foot monster yeah like why would you
do that yeah I love that because you
know what I feel when I hear that is
there's a certain humility when you
recognize that Consciousness awareness
that's that's looking at your eyes right
now that's it's like how are you how do
you know what you're hearing because you
are aware yeah right so that is a
miracle and I've said this million times
but it's almost over I think it's so
funny that we're like pens it's almost
over that's what I always warn people
I'm like if it sounds like I'm repeating
myself at least I'm almost done oh God
it's like we're magical pens filled with
this miraculous fluid however you want
to Picture This it could be golden and
molten it's amazing it's it's blinding
light yeah and so many of you use that
ink to write this is [__] which is
so funny oh I love that the mechanism
great with which you are determining of
course it is yeah and you're you tell me
you're not saying that on stage oh you
think that's a bit yes give me that pen
are you kidding me come on what are we
doing all right so we have Mike's doing
his
best um we had Jason Bourne I heard
mayel laugh at
that and um Magic Pen Magic Pen this is
[__] um but that that what you're
saying is it's kind of what I've said in
another bit it's like like nothing
really makes sense so like why would
anything be any weirder than this every
time I wake up in the night to pee I go
oh
right I'm in
this like what and a lot of us because
you're you're like oh my God I'm in this
body I'm in this body I'm in this world
that has to like excrete
water and you know what I say most times
when I pee I go in this dream you can
pee that's funny in your dream dreams
that's a good bit too by the way in this
dream you can be I you're one of these
people melan's like this too when I
first met
melanion God floating in the
barbasol I love it oh my God I'm being
preserved oh my
God Sarah Sherman did an impression of
melany on SNL the other night that was
very very funny we watched it yeah as a
gr very funny
I hope Sarah squirm squirm she goes by
both oh squirm squirm is her stage name
Sherman's her real name oh I didn't know
I've only known her his squirm uh Sarah
Sherman would be happy to know that me
Jed Oto you not that we're special but
like anybody that can a bunch of comics
put on a YouTube and just play it and
kill yeah killed in the room yeah yeah
but yeah but but but uh I'm sorry you
were saying I cut you off no I I said
you can pee in this stream oh yeah I
would do that b oh the reason I brought
up melany is when I first met meany he's
one of those people
where half the things he says when I'm
with him I go do you have that in the
act and he goes no yeah we write it down
and then he'll literally take out his
phone be
like yeah okay like he's unaware of how
funny he is all the time it's like the
sink is leak comedy yeah in fact that
that was the image I had he's like Wily
Wonka in a candy factory I know it's
Chocolate Factory but I'm he's the real
deal and I from jump I've known him I've
known him since he was like I've known
him since he was like 21 years old it's
like just is a riot yeah just is a riot
of uh observations and it's and it
honestly is I think this is he can't
shut his brain off yeah he's like an
Insurrection
of like it's involuntary like we can't
stop it
yeah but but you're like that in the
sense that like I'm telling you like
four things to write down that's only
I'm still skeptical but yeah well that's
me literally withholding saying that 10
other times during this conversation oh
that's nice I'm not that's that's me
being like the format of my podcast
working it out is working out bits and
me being like that's a bit that's a bit
that it's not even the format of yours
I'm like I got to tell you this that's a
bit I'm sorry to interrup this is this
is what's interesting about going back
to your brilliant thing that you said
Comics are often clearly not saying what
they're actually thinking yeah and
feeling one of the great things about
podcasting but also just friendship and
conversation and why you can't do this
in a vacuum and why we inherently don't
trust Comics that don't hang yeah never
hang oh that's interesting and never
never hang the never hang Comics you're
in a rental car and not shooting the
[__] with you I've had that they're just
on their phone or something and you're
like oh my God what are we doing like
talking about aiz like that just kidding
I love the opening for you it was the
highlight of my life I'm sorry I have
social
anxiety I can't talk to you in the car
I'm on my phone the battery died 20
minutes ago I'm looking at a black
screen no now I got a flip phone now I
got a flip phone cuz it's a problem
Kane Kan oh my God you can watch this
all
day you're about to
stop uh but that we know it's not
created in a vacuum so sometimes these
conversations and what's so great about
your podcast is you need someone from
the outside like a therapist yeah that
goes oh I you go to a marriage counselor
they're like a doctor and they go this
is where the the issues in your pan is
yeah and you didn't know and sometimes a
comic goes that it's like what you did
with my vasectomy thing it's like
actually the joke is kind of
about how hard it is parenting is
ungodly difficult yeah and I know it's a
cliche to tack this on but I have to
it's like it's my favorite thing it's
the only thing it's my only thing I love
it more than anything and Val and I
sometimes look at each other like it's
like Saving Private Ryan and I'm like
why did did I turn down the
cigarettes remember that moment yeah
he's like they were giving out free
cigarettes and I said I don't smoke it's
like everybody smokes well that's that's
that's a joke Jenny and I I'll always
say about uh my you know Jenny and I
worked on the new one special uh which
is also a book it's called the new one
it's all if people don't know cuz edit
that out if people don't know it's a
it's a it's a it's a book and a special
that has Jen's poetry and my comedy
about how
you know I never wanted to have a child
and all the reasons I never want to have
a child and how I was right and then how
I was wrong and then Jen's perspective
which is expressed through poetry
because she's an introvert and she
expresses herself through poetry and uh
and it intertwines with that and a lot
of times people will ask us how is UNA
your daughter going to feel about this
and and and we say we always say like
she knows and she just doesn't even
believe believe it's true because she
can't imagine a universe where the
person where I this completely doting
father who's completely obsessed with
every tennis stroke she takes and
cartwheel she makes would not want to
have a child she can't conceive of that
right yeah oh I love that it's
also she starts laughing when we bring
it up no see what what we're saying
is children like you and I who we all
experience some form I know the word
gets overused but of trauma of something
that was not ideal and we know what it's
like to be in
situations where we know but no one's
talking about it yeah and that is
unacceptable yeah and that's a wonderful
thing to say that you can turn the tide
of a pattern like that you can make the
AR Army marched the other way the this
isn't my family and I would tell you if
it was but there are so many families
that I've seen or people have asked
about I just did motion Natasha's
podcast somebody called in with a
question like this families have
narratives families have
mythologies and when a new person comes
in like you marry somebody and they show
up yeah sometimes they're like they
didn't get the script yeah and they are
like is he having a third bottle of
wine and no and and you recognize this
is why David Lynch movies and the the
attack of the robot people and all these
things it's like that's us you think
zombies don't exist you're you're this
person you know that's a zombie that's
pretending that they don't see something
or or vampires don't exist people who
drain and hoarde that's the 1% you know
what I mean these these this is why
there's a whole other ball of wax about
movies right now this is why a lot of
people people are saying that movies
right now are less realistic and they're
mo more based on
abstract universes and worlds because
people don't want to they want to escape
from what's happening right now which is
horrible I I thought it was because we
need the Guardians of the Galaxy to go
into another planet where everything's a
drawer and there's Bubbles and Aliens
because that's what the internet feels
like see I don't know which comes first
Leela being interested in Ninja Turtles
and being introduced to violence or
Leela having like a yian archetype of a
violence a mo a propensity a model of
aggression that she's dreaming about
yeah and she needs reflected back to her
to interpret it and distance herself
from it and and process it so which
comes first Raphael kicking Shredder or
Leela kicking the shredder of a child
you know when you pick up your kid from
school and you're like oh this is Lord
of the Flies you know what I mean like
someone just took her ball and ran away
someone just sneezed on her hair I'm
like this is like prison yeah you know
what I mean she so she has those
feelings and she doesn't know what to do
with them she watches the Ninja Turtles
and she's like right there's a force in
me that can fight those aggressions that
can push them away there's there's two
things that war inside of us so we're
sort of lenient in that way I'm not
going to let her watch it but like at
the same point why do grown-ups watch it
right cuz you probably want to like you
know kill someone in your family and you
don't know how you feel about that or
whatever it might be who in your family
who is it that you want to kill not
literally but we all know what it's like
who is it I have dreams that I'm
fighting my dad a lot I mean that that's
a dream and and sometimes it's my
brother I love these guys I do I'm I'm
being real yeah I know and I wake up and
I feel that like what's going on I had a
dream the other night that I was was
hitting my brother with a set of car
keys I'm hitting him on the head and I'm
like what was that and then I watch a
movie that gets into that muck and I go
thank you thank you why look at look at
our art it's so weird I don't like
horror movies very much like I don't
consume them I like the ones I've seen
whatever but why it's such an
interesting loophole that we have as a
society that we're like pretty careful
about what you can say I'm I'm with it I
get it that's triggering that's
offensive but we'll also flock in record
numbers to a movie where like someone
decapitates a horse and [__] the non
headside yeah and we're like yeah saw is
back and it's like weird but that to me
is this remnant of a tribal
understanding of sometimes someone puts
on the wicked red mask and they took a
dump on the fire last night and and it
healed killed me for some
reason yeah that that was um this is I
was at a
party where Darren aronowski who made
the
wrestler you know Darren aronowski the
great film director he made Black Swan a
bunch of other stuff but I I I've been
drinking too much which I rarely do I
don't even really drink almost ever you
look like you should have a
pedy like I'd love to get you some
insure oh my God something something
with phytonutrients okay so that wasn't
what my story is about but
um so um I I was so drunk that I asked
Darren aronovsky I'm like at the end of
the wrestler why does he have to
die and it's so like I think of myself
as not the person who walks up to the
director of the wrestler and asks them a
question that he doesn't really want to
talk about yeah but uh what did he say
because
he he dies so that the so that the
audience can experience it but not have
to live it precisely and that's it
that's right we want a third person
death yeah that's what third person
death you'll never see a I don't think
you'll see many movies it's one of the
reasons why The Sopranos was so jarring
because it was a first- person death you
know what I mean it was from his
perspective it went black and we hated
that right we want our death's third
person because that's what we want our
own death to be it's like Woody Allen
I'm not afraid of death I just don't
want to be there when it happens we want
to be a depersonalized Observer of Our
Own Death like I don't mind seeing Pete
get hit by a bus but to be in his head
like like that's not fun one of the
reason why VR is so jarring that's that
and that's with old man in the
pool that was the goal was
to how can we laugh about the thing that
we're not laughing about um in a way
that doesn't feel contrived that was my
goal I mean there's like a handful of
times in the show where I talk about
people close to me
dying um my family going through medical
issues near-death man medical issues my
grandfather dying Etc and it's like I
think that that the thing that you're
describing about horror movies and
extreme things it's the same appeal in a
certain way is is the reason why people
like it is because they're going through
the thing with me and at the end they
walk out and they're like oh I feel
pretty I feel some gratitude about my
existence right now every night I die
every morning I'm reborn is is a nice
one for me was that on like the back of
like a a cocktail napkin or something
you wouldn't know it cuz it wasn't on
the back of a pack of ramen noodles that
you put chicken powder on what do you
mean by and go Jen I had a good meal
today it was very lean very lean and I
slurped it up and I think the doctor
says I have another couple weeks who is
this an impression of I ate some ramen
noodles because I'm on a high carb
diet but who's the impression of I don't
even get it not even doing you
anymore because it's it takes too long
to actually do you it's too drawn out
like I want to do it but I don't want to
ruin the comedy I'd slip into your voice
but I don't want to ruin the comedy
the the burn you said of me on the my
podcast pH is I'm like a podcast at half
speed yeah you are you are a slow boy
but you know what I get off stage and I
go oh thank God I went slow I'm always
trying to go
slower you might want to take a note
from me and go the other way just
kidding you're
perfect to end where we have to end no
I'll tell you I'll tell you exactly
what's going on so so your you have you
have to yeah you have to get to the
train station it right now by the way it
says 24 minutes which means if you left
at 11: in 10 minutes from now yeah you'd
be there at 11:24 I scheduled the ride
share I won't say which one I used for
fear that there's always some
scare you know what I mean of course you
don't know sometimes you go like I just
Amazon that people are
like I didn't know I didn't know yeah we
know though that's one of the things we
know that we don't know we all walk into
apartments and it looks like they just
moved in because there's so many Amazon
boxes yeah I think that's true we're all
just looking the other way on that so
we're an hour into this podcast is there
any is there any moment where I'm gonna
talk you're very funny well if we can
get one of those things that you blow
like a fire with to like encourage the
flame if we could stick that in you and
maybe maybe we could make you talk
reanimate you so if people in the
comments section of Apple podcast could
just go right now and just say
why doesn't Pete Holmes let Mike biglia
talk that would be really helpful thank
you much at my sore subjects also say
why does he laugh at his own
jokes what are yours what are yours what
gets your goat I really because real
quick I interrupt and Jive because I'm
like if you want to listen to a [__]
stale ass interview listen to Mike bigl
on any other pod if you want information
go to Wikipedia sorry what did you just
say what what did you just say
what do you mean repeat what you just
said if you want like a straight ahead
interview with Mike biglia listen to any
other podcast but what do you get on
this just you talking very good when you
were
Ant-Man and you reanimated to a regular
size why didn't your liver grow back
like you seem to not be processing
toxins why didn't your liver grow back
what I'm saying is cruel it's a piece of
uh conversation art there you go and I
laugh at my own Jud there you go what
there you go and then the other thing
why do I laugh at my own jokes we were
talking about this last night how you
said you had a friend who watched my
special and we like he laughs mom's mom
which is fine which is fine can we keep
it in all right's mom's mom your like
the special like mayel like the special
Mabel's mom said like the special why
does he laugh at his own jokes it's fine
and to Mabel's mom Tracy and to everyone
who are I hear the caring in there you
know what I mean there's some care
there's some interest in comedy and
what's good pull that away sure taste
yeah take that out but uh I said to you
I go you know I've tried it both ways
yeah and everything I'm doing is to
Delight you everything oh is that what
it is nothing we can do I don't think
we're picking it up these are
unidirectional
microphones okay I don't hear yeah
okay so anyway every everything I do on
stage is to Delight you it's it's all
this benevolent trick to get us to a joy
place you've I've done it both ways you
think I can't stop myself from laughing
I can and I don't because it's better if
I do yeah and I like doing it as well so
everybody there it is Tracy there it is
Tracy we did we dedicate this to you
what were you saying though you were
about to oh I was going to say this all
the teasing aside I love you so much I
love you that's how I thought we could
close beautiful I no I mean like if you
wanted to say other nice
things oh that's my
alarm that's your your alarm just went
off to remind you to leave well I have
to go in 7 minutes I don't I said alarms
I said alarms on the mtrk you don't want
to miss your stuff
um I love you I love you too I think
you're one of the greats a you're out
there you know you are your Disney World
it's like curated it's clean it's nice
it's interesting I don't want to be
Disney World no I don't mean in every
way I'm just talking about the
Landscaping just the Landscaping just
the Landscaping yeah who what the hell
kind of compliment is that I'm the rides
that's like saying you're you're you're
like the you're like the Death Star just
the engine it's got a really good
engine no when you're older and you go
to Disneyland with your daughter this is
how I know I'm 44 I go look at those
trees those have those have improved oh
my God those are nice that takes effort
this
one's okay okay we're good we're good
we're all good I love you buddy I love
you too and and
uh yeah uh what no I think we're good I
think we're good I think is that does
that give you closure how how do you get
closure at the end of your episod you
say keep it crispy oh right okay that
but oh yeah we covered God stuff I'm
trying to think of the things in your
podcast that we didn't get to oh okay
you want a classic yeah what's the time
in your life you laughed harder than any
other time you've ever laughed so mine
is when I'm with my my and Jenny always
knows all about this because she's like
it's an Unstoppable Force when Mike is
home with his family over like Christmas
sitting standing around like the kitchen
aisle you know late at night yeah
telling stories about when we were kids
and everyone just laughing and laughing
my brothers and sisters and and uh
there's nothing funnier than that that's
great and
uh and uh yeah so we got say keep it
crispy but but I got to have a a way to
say it well this is what normally
happens I love that answer what a
beautiful answer but I say we end the
show with the guest saying keep it
crispy it doesn't mean anything would
you say keep it
crispy I'm trying to I'm trying to
capture you on
stage
why AR you laughing I'm saying keep it
crispy I'm saying it keep it crispy can
I pitch a line yeah if I was in the
crowd I'd be losing my mind right now
that's right keep it
crispy
you you made it you made it oh yeah you
made it you made it with you made it wi
oh yeah you made it win you made it with
you made it with oh yeah you made it
with you made it with you made it with
all